Formula One racing through Las Vegas in
seven months but who is paying for all
this yeah the nearly four mile race it's
going to be on County roads all of which
need to be repaved to meet those High F1
standards Ryan Matthey joining us from
Sands between Las Vegas Boulevard and
sphere to see what he's found
well repaving will be ongoing at least
until a couple months before the race
day it started here along Sands Avenue
on Sunday night but the project it's
unlike how Clark County typically does
business and as of now taxpayer dollars
could be used to help fund it
an internationally recognized sport
racing towards Las Vegas for a three-day
event we anticipate a lifetime together
that's commissioner Jim Gibson back in
February when a unanimous vote
designated Formula One as an annual
event in Clark County this will open the
pathway to be able to do it for at least
10 years
but while the county would typically use
a bidding process to hire construction
companies that wasn't the case for this
road project the county confirms
repaving the nearly four miles of
publicly owned track is the
responsibility of the privately owned
company who hired Las Vegas Paving
without the bidding process we have a
tight time frame to do this the lack of
copy petition not a concern to Laborers
Local 872 business manager Tommy White
if so many other contractors out there
wanted a piece of what was going on with
formula one they could have jumped in
early on then comes the price tag which
hasn't been announced just yet but lvcva
President Steve Hill indicating during a
March board meeting that F1 asked them
for help I think the initial request
they put in was for 37 million dollars
Which is less than half of what the cost
of the entire circuit would be while an
F1 spokesperson declined to provide any
updates on the project a County
spokesperson said they're still debating
whether or not to use taxpayer dollars
to help cover the cost